I'd like to begin with a personal story
my grandmother was the daughter of a
woman who was the child of persons who
were enslaved on Rose Hill plantation in
North Carolina and as a consequence my
sister and I are the fourth generation
removed from slavery my grandmother also
lived in a town in North Carolina called
Wilson which was a tobacco stapling
Center and she lived in a town that was
characterized by the classic pattern
that that's featured in many many
southern towns in the United States
there was a railroad track that ran
between the black side of town and the
white side of town as an act of
separation that was emblematic of the
Jim Crow period in the United States
there was a point at which I wanted to
go and see a movie happen to be a Disney
movie after all an old Disney movie
called Darby O'Gill and the little
people but it was being shown at the
white theatre in Wilson North Carolina
and my parents refused to let me go
because they said we would be compelled
to sit in the balcony and they viewed
this as an indignity that they were not
going to stomach
and so I wasn't able to go I was very
hurt because I really wanted to see this
movie but I also came to realize as I
grew a bit older that this was an
indignity that was relatively minor in a
social context in which lynchings and
white massacres had become quite routine
so I would like to emphasize that when
we think about the case for reparations
we are thinking about a case that is not
exclusively centered on the harms and in
justices and atrocities associated with
slavery itself but we have to view
slavery as a crucible that created a
subsequent or
Raye of atrocities that are associated
with white supremacy in the united
states and those atrocities include
those that were the product of slavery
itself but also of nearly 100 years of
legal segregation in the United States
accompanied by white mob violence and
frequent frequent intervals and and so
we usually refer to that as the Jim Crow
period and I want to emphasize when
people say there no living victims of
slavery there certainly are a number of
us who are living victims of the Jim
Crow period of course if the nation
waits long enough to engage in an act of
redemption and compensation we won't be
alive any longer but a national act of
procrastination is not a justification
for avoiding paying the debt and then of
course in the aftermath of the period of
legal segregation the post-civil rights
act error we have a set of circumstances
in which there were ongoing atrocities
inclusive of mass incarceration police
executions of unarmed blacks the
persistence of discrimination and
employment housing and credit markets as
well as something that I'm going to
emphasize and the remainder of my
comments the immense racial wealth gap
in the United States now in our book
from here to equality which is authored
with Kirsten Mullen who happens to be my
spouse in our book we define reparations
as a program of acknowledgement redress
and closure for a grievous injustice
acknowledgement constitutes a
circumstance in which the culpable party
acknowledges or recognizes that it has
committed a vicious harm and it also
benefited from the execution of this
vicious harm redress is the act of
restitution on the part of the culpable
party and here we're going to talk in a
moment
about about the role of the wealth
differential in the United States
between blacks and whites as a critical
component of of a redress process for
black American descendants of us slavery
the final component is closure which is
a point at which the culpable party in
the victimized community come to an
agreement that the debt has been paid
and no further claim will be made unless
there's a renewal of the atrocities that
have taken place in the past or a new
array of atrocities is forthcoming so I
want to focus next on the wealth
differential and the wealth differential
is best captured by the magnitude of
these types of differences in black and
white wealth black Americans constitute
approximately 13% of the nation's
population but only possess about 2.6
percent of the nation's wealth
collectively across the globe there's
approximately 300 trillion dollars in
wealth a hundred trillion dollars or
about a third of that is in the
possession of American citizens and
ninety percent of that is in the
possession of white Americans so we have
a situation in which black Americans
constitute a much much higher percentage
of the u.s. population than they do in
terms of their share in in the nation's
wealth this translates into a
circumstance in which the average black
household has approximately eight
hundred thousand dollars less in net
worth than the average white household
another way to think about this is as
the fact that there are three white
billionaires Jeff Bezos
Bill Gates and Warren Buffett who were
worth more than the collective 80
percent of black Americans who are at
the lower end of the wealth distribution
but it's not just a matter of the
billionaires wealth that explains this
gaping differential for example white
Americans 25%
white Americans have a net worth in
excess of 1 million dollars but it's
only 4% of black Americans and wealth is
important in terms of being
distinguished from income wealth is a
stock concept it's the difference
between the value of what we own and
what we owe the net property of our
value excuse me the net value of our
property income in contrast is is a flow
concept that's most closely associated
with our earnings and wealth is more
significant than income in terms of
providing us with Economic Security and
opportunities to fully participate in
the society wealthier households have
the capacity to survive income losses
that might be associated with
unemployment or medical emergencies
wealthier families can provide their
children with high quality education and
debt free education wealthier families
can have access to high amenity
neighborhoods they can also purchase
legal counsel valuable legal counsel
when confronted with the criminal
justice system wealthier families can
leave the quest to subsequent
generations to ensure their economic
security and well-being so wealth is
extremely significant and the
differentials that exist between blacks
and whites are connected to sharp
differences in Economic Opportunity and
well-being indeed it's very important to
note that the major factor that does
that dictates what an individual or a
family's level of wealth is is the
transfer of resources across generations
which means in turn that wealth captures
the cumulative intergenerational effects
of white supremacy in the United States
when we think about the black/white
differentials and so in from here to
equality we argue that the goal of a
reparations program a goal that is
associated with the redress component of
reparations is to eliminate the racial
wealth gap and this would be done
primarily through direct
to eligible recipients black American
descendants of us slavery in the book we
identify two standards for eligibility
the first criteria is what we refer to
as a lineage criteria an eligible
individual would have to demonstrate
that they have at least one ancestor who
was enslaved in the United States and
the second criterion is what we refer to
as an identity criterion and this is a
criterion that says that an individual
would have to show that for at least 12
years before the onset of a reparations
program the enactment of a reparations
program or the enactment of a study
commissioned for a reparations program
whichever comes first for at least 12
years before that an individual would
have to have shown that they
self-identified as black Negro or
African American the culpable party for
making the payment is the United States
government the magnitude of the payment
must be sufficient to eliminate racial
wealth differentials within the course
of a decade like to add finally that the
corona virus epidemic only further
dramatizes the case for reparations
we've observed excess mortality on the
part of black Americans we've observed a
collapse in black businesses in black
employment opportunities and we've
observed a high degree of crisis in
terms of opportunities for education as
our instructional environment has
shifted from the classroom into the home
via the internet so as a consequence we
argue that it's important to continue to
commit to the case for reparations in
the midst of the pandemic it's always an
urgent time to adopt reparations it has
been an urgent time for a hundred two
fifty five years since the end of
American slavery where no restitution
has been
provided it's time for the nation to pay
the debt it's time for racial justice
and borrowing from Chloe of all dari I'd
like to say that we collectively must
become enchanted with the goal of racial
equality thank you so much sandy for for
all of that and for explaining your book
a little bit and also talking to this
moment and I think in thinking about
this moment you know obviously the
subject of reparations is not a new one
it's something that we have been having
conversations about for a very long time
and you know I think that when you think
about what we're experiencing right now
both related to the pandemic and
violence against the black community the
conversation often does sort of look at
reparations as a way forward and I'd
love to hear you to sort of explain why
you feel this moment might be different
from others in making progress towards
towards this I think that there has been
a shift in the terrain that became
evident in 2019 even prior to the corona
virus pandemic and prior to the
widespread recognition of the phenomenon
of anti black police violence which the
black community has been well aware of
for for a long long time even prior to
that I think in 2019 there was a signal
shift in the in in the environment with
respect to attention that's being given
to reparations I'm not sure how to
explain why that was the case but for
the first time in my lifetime we had
serious and credible political figures
who were contesting for the presidency
of the United States actually uttering
the term reparations and potentially
talking about whether or not there would
be the grounds for introducing some sort
of study commission for reparations
through congressional legislation that
had never happened before in my lifetime
and it seemed to me in 29
that the nation was having the most
animated conversation about reparations
at on the political stage that had ever
taken place since the Reconstruction era
in the United States so I think that the
more recent chain of events has produced
greater momentum for serious
consideration of this idea I think
people are no longer dismissing it out
of hand I think they're trying to think
about what the consequences would be for
our nation of adopting a reparations
program for black American descendants
of slavery in terms of our moral future
as well as our social future
collectively and so the the idea of
reparations of course stems from this
this concept of forty eight percent of
you will write that during that the
abolition of slavery after the abolition
of slavery rather freed slaves would
receive forty acres and a mule promised
that the government of course never made
good on and so I let's look into some of
the details of the plan that you put
forward in terms of thinking first about
what the value really is of that forty
acres in a mule today so in other terms
you know how do you quantify the full
debt that you believe is owed to
descendents of American slaves in 2020
so the the moment of the failure to
provide the forty acres is really is
really a critical epoch in American
history you know I think it shapes the
the basis for the immense racial wealth
gap that we observed today so if we
start with the moment and the immediate
aftermath of the civil war where the
formerly enslaved were promised forty
acre land allotments the minimum
estimate of what that that amount of
land should have constituted would have
been about forty million acres what
happened initially was about four forty
thousand of the formerly enslaved
individuals were settled on four hundred
thousand acres out of the allotment the
General Sherman had had specified in
special orders number fifteen which came
closer to five point three million acres
stretching from South Carolina
to northern Florida but only only
400,000 acres were actually ever settled
and toward the end of 1865 Andrew
Johnson Lincoln's successor after
Lincoln was murdered Andrew Johnson
reverses the policy of settlement of the
formerly enslaved altogether and
restores the land to the former slave
holders now at the same time the
homestead acts were being activated in
the United States providing large tracts
of land to white settlers in the western
part of the United States on tracts of
land that had been appropriated and
seized from the Native American
population in fact those allotments were
a hundred sixty acre allotments and we
estimate today that anywhere from forty
five million to ninety million Americans
are beneficiaries of those allocations
because of the intergenerational effects
of wealth transfers so so this is the
starting point we could use the present
value of the forty million acres as an
estimate as a lower bound estimate of
what the magnitude of a reparations bill
should be and in the work that we've
done this comes to approximately four to
six trillion dollars depending upon
which interest rate you use to compound
to the present but in the work that we
do we also argue that what's really
critical is to address the gaping racial
wealth gap of black white wealth
differential and to do that it would
require somewhere in the vicinity of ten
to twelve trillion dollars at the low
end estimate of what would be required
for for erasure of that of that
differential well and then from that ten
trillion dollars we're talking about
individual payments or payments are the
two individuals this is not about money
being funneled into two programs but
actual checks that individual
descendants of American slaves would
receive is that right yes so the idea
here is that if you're going to
the racial wealth differential you have
to do it by by taking the precise step
of providing direct payments to the
individuals who are eligible if you go
the indirect route you will have a
dilution of the delivery of the
resources to the individuals who deserve
them or merit them so for example if you
pursued some sort of neighborhood based
or community based operation in a world
in which gentrification is running
rampant it would be very difficult to
ensure that the resources would go to
the folks who are supposed to receive
them so so yes one of the central
objectives of a reparations program is
to provide direct payments to the
eligible recipients I'm certainly
open-minded about the prospect of having
other kinds of programmatic initiatives
that could be that could be pursued for
example providing resources and funds to
historically black colleges and
universities might be a potential option
of what could be done with the
reparations fund but for substantive and
symbolic reasons the preponderant use of
the funds must be direct payments to
eligible recipients and let me add when
when I talk about payments I don't
necessarily mean cash payments per se
the objective is to eliminate the racial
wealth gap so what you really want to do
is to build assets for black Americans
and those assets could be could be built
in the form of trust accounts or
endowments not necessarily in the form
of outright cash payments so so there
they're a number of options in the way
in which you could provide individual
eligible recipients with the resources
from a reparations project and I mean I
think one of the big questions for a lot
of people is sort of where where do we
see find this money are you do you
anticipate that it's on the weight of
tax dollars is this something that is
you know rerouted from other programs
where do we get the money so I think
that I start with a rejection of the
scarcity principle
that underlines the view that you have
to take money from pot a to produce
money for pot B I think that our most
recent experience with the overnight
provision of approximately two and a
half trillion dollars to try to cope in
some way with the coronavirus crisis
indicates that the federal government is
not constrained by tax payments to
proceed with making new expenditures so
so from my perspective the government
can simply set up a program of
reparations payments and create the
resources or create the funds that would
that would address the needed amounts
you could do it over a period of years
to make the annual Vig not quite as high
you could do it over the course of a
decade for example but there's there's
no there's no tax based constraint or
revenue based constraint on the capacity
of the federal government to make
additional expenditures the only
substantive constraint is the potential
for producing high rates of inflation
and so you would necessarily have to
design a reparations project or any new
expenditure program in such a way that
you mitigated the inflation risk but
that's the only barrier and so I don't
see us having to cut off cut off other
programs or avoid other kinds of
valuable initiatives for the purposes of
financing a reparations project now I
want to get into some of the the
criticisms of not just your plan but
reparations in general but first let's
some a second question from audience so
Paul Rucker asks full reparations work
if the current system stay in place
seems like payment for reparations up
payment of reparations excuse me would
quickly go back to the white community
so there was a sketch on Dave Chapelle
show when it was still on the air
and which reparations were given to
black Americans and all the money flowed
back to white American corporations
because of their there was no
infrastructure of black businesses that
folks could actually purchase on
purchase products from so so one
response to this question is the money
wouldn't quickly go back to the white
community if a an important aspect of a
reparations project was the development
of of black businesses or black
enterprises so that's one one answer the
second answer is associated with the
point that I made a moment ago that
there are multiple ways in which the
payments could be made and if the
payments are made in the form of an
endowment or a trust or or what we call
in more technical language and economics
less liquid assets it's kind of a clumsy
term but that's that's what we say if
the if the payments are made in that
form you wouldn't have the money flowing
out to any one in in in an instantaneous
fashion people would have would have to
make more discrete decisions about how
to use the funds and when to use the
funds and so you potentially could have
resources being devoted by individual
black Americans to infrastructure
development within the black community
where there would be an opportunity to
actually purchase purchase goods and
services from from other members of the
black community so so I think you know
it's it's a question of whether or not
you have a black business infrastructure
and it's a question of whether or not
the payments are made in such a way that
they're not outright cash payments that
flow immediately out of people's hands
you know one of the things that's really
compelling for me in talking with you is
that I know that you were at one point
not supportive of the idea of
reparations and so I'm curious to hear
what sort of made you skeptical and what
changed your feelings so around 1989
an economist named Richard America
approached me about writing the
introduction to a volume that he had
assembled where he had requested a group
of economists to construct estimates of
the magnitude of a reparations program
and at the time I told Richard well you
know I think reparations is something
that's ethically ethically sound but I
don't think it's ever gonna happen that
this is something that's really in the
vein of speculative fiction and it's
just not going to occur so why are we
going to invest time and trying to
trying to work on a reparations project
or collect essays about how much it
would actually cost and Richard said to
me and with with great wisdom I didn't
realize the depth of the wisdom at that
time but he said read the essays and
write whatever you choose to write but I
want you specifically to write the
introduction so I proceeded to read the
essays and the more that I read the more
that I became convinced that not only
was a reparations project for black
American descendants of US slavery
something that was vital to do from a
moral standpoint but it was vital to do
from a practical standpoint and that
even if the odds were extremely long of
actually having a reparations program
come into realization that it was
something that I was obligated to pursue
and so it was in the process of working
on Richards book which was later called
the wealth of races that I came to the
point where I began to say that I had to
do research and I have to do advocacy
work in favor of reparations climbing
land let's talk a little bit of I think
about some of the criticisms that people
do have of reparations you know I think
first one of the big ones you hear is if
if this is a way to
close the wealth gap you know is it
really fair that you know descendants of
slaves who have earned themselves into
the 1% would also be eligible to receive
these checks and how do you respond to
to those who say that could you clarify
Whitney what you mean by 1% I'm not sure
that I understand yeah I mean so
basically just if you're thinking about
the Oprah Winfrey's of the world the you
know descendants of slaves who are you
know millionaires and billionaires and
you know how can you justify payments
for those so a reparations project is
not an anti-poverty program it's an act
of justice restitution that has never
been paid before and so there is no
criteria associated with the conditions
of living eligible recipients that
should block them from access now if
individuals like and Oprah Winfrey said
I'm so wealthy this this payment really
is not of importance to me I'd rather it
go to somebody else
that's their discretion but they
certainly are eligible to receive it
when reparations payments were made to
victims of the Holocaust by the German
German government there was no inquiry
about the economic status of the
eligible recipients when reparations
payments were made to japanese-americans
in the United States to compensate to
some to some degree for their unjust
incarceration during World War two no
one asks how much is that particular
individual earning or how much are they
worth before they were we're given their
$20,000 payments so so I think the same
is true here this is not a matter of how
well individual black people are doing
today this is a matter of the collective
difference in black wealth and white
wealth and that's what has to be spanned
and any black American who is a
descendant of persons who was
we're enslaved in the United States is
eligible to receive it it should be a
matter of their discretion as to whether
or not they take it and then for those
who also think you know this money maybe
we'll be better served if it were funded
into social service service programs you
know if you're thinking about money that
might support failing education systems
or think about money that might support
police perform in other ways that sort
of prevent black Americans from
attaining and maintaining wealth what
are your feelings about that so none of
those approaches that I've seen
particularly kind of social programs and
some grandsons Universal programs of
redistribution none of the ones that
I've ever seen would meet the task of
eliminating the black/white wealth
differential in the United States none
of them have the capacity or the
wherewithal to erase the black/white
differential and wealth and so there's
there simply not sufficient they're not
enough and and I'm particularly taken by
the emphasis a lot of people want a
place on providing resources for
education and as as a university
professor of course I'm fairly
passionate about educational attainment
I'd be a hypocrite if I wasn't but but
in terms of thinking about the racial
wealth gap educational attainment
doesn't hold much promise at all and see
here's a notorious statistic that I
think is very telling on this score
black heads of households with a college
degree have 2/3 of the net worth of
white heads of households who never
finished high school so you're not going
to eliminate the racial wealth gap
simply by giving black people more and
better education because you're not
going to interrupt the intergenerational
transmission effects that are associated
with moving resources from one generator
to the next if you continue to have a
community that doesn't have any
resources to transfer to subsequent
generations and let's take another
question from the audience so amma asks
i'm concerned about proving eligibility
not because of the challenges of being
able to track down genealogy records but
also because of the exclusion of members
of the African Diaspora who have lived
live in the United States can you speak
more on this issue yes so first of all
there's no question that the types of
criteria that I've talked about for
eligibility will give genealogist a huge
amount of business but one thing that
we've proposed in the final chapter of
from here to equality which is the
chapter where we detail a program of
reparations is that the federal
government in the process of
establishing the reparations project
could provide resources to individuals
who are trying to establish their their
legitimate claims for reparations
resources for the genealogical research
there could be an agency that could be
established that would do the
genealogical research on behalf of of
individual claimants and so I don't
think that that's an impossibility the
other issue that's raised by in the
question here is the is are the contours
of who would be included and who is
excluded from this particular type of
reparations project and yes the
individuals who are more recent black
immigrants to the United States
particularly after the 1960's which is
the the vast majority of recent black
immigrants to the United States they
would not be eligible for this program
and they would not be eligible because
the anchor for this program is the
failure to provide the formerly enslaved
with the 40 acres that they merited
at the end of the period of enslavement
and this failure is what has had long
repercussions for living black American
descendants of us slavery individuals
who are more recent immigrants from
other African countries don't share that
particular historical historical affect
or historical moment and I think that
that's what defines the unique position
of this particular claim if folks
believe that more recent black
immigrants do have some form of
reparations claim then I encourage them
to try to develop it but it's not the
same one that's based upon the
cumulative effects of slavery Jim Crow
and ongoing white atrocities in the
United States and you know you so you've
been doing this work for a long time and
I think as we're running out of time
here I'm just curious about your
sentiments about how you you feel in
terms of the progress that has been made
towards this and how how far away or
closer you feel we are to seeing a plan
like yours realized or any sort of
restitution realized for descendants of
American slaves so like most economists
I'm horrendous at forecasting and so I'm
not entirely sure you know what what's
going to evolve I will say this the
momentum that exists in the present
moment is promising and I would say that
you know in in the year 2000 when
Michael Dawson and Ravana pop off did a
major survey they found that only 4% of
white Americans were in favor of
reparations for black Americans that
figure is closer to about 20% now and
and almost half of all Millennials are
in favor of reparations so so the
direction seems to be going in in the
proper way and I think that there is a
significant amount of support at minimum
for the creation of a common
to study reparations the prelude to the
japanese-american reparations was a
commission called the Commission on
wartime relocation and internment of
civilians and there should be a parallel
Commission as a prelude to Black
American reparations and the possibility
of doing that is embodied in a piece of
legislation called House Resolution 40 I
will say that there are some serious
limitations and weaknesses in the
existing legislation as currently
constructed and I think that before we
go forward with passage of that
legislation which seems to be quite
possible we need to actually revise its
content but apart from that I think that
that would be a key step in moving in
the direction of a comprehensive
reparations program for black American
descendants of US slavery